hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle
Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicejokerslive.com
folks Joe DeRosa here from the taste
buds show and I got other shows live
shows not within these four walls but
out there on the big open road and here
in New York City where I live let's
start with the residency of my new hour
show I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
next one is at the crane theater on
January 25th all of them are at the
crane theater uh one after that will be
February 14th which is Valentine's Day
for all you sweeties and there's another
one coming up in March check out that if
you're in the city also if you're in New
York on February 8th I'll be at the City
Winery as a special guest of an evening
with cooge my man couge my favorite food
influencer that's going to be a lot of
fun doing a round table discussion about
food and stuff like that February 18th
the JFL just for last Festival I will be
at the Biltmore Cabaret in Vancouver
British Columbia Columbia March 9th
Baton Rouge at the manship theater
Lafayette Louisiana Club 337 on March
10th March 11th New Orleans at The
Howlin Wolf and my March 30th in
Hamtramck Michigan at the independent
Comedy Club there are consecutive dates
on March 31st April 1st and April 2nd in
that same general area that will be
announced I know for sure one of them is
in Chicago but we're announcing those
soon uh anyway go to jotarosainfo.com
for all show times and ticket links and
information and then also as always if
you are in New York City come down to
Joey roses the bar sandwich shop open
seven days a week we open at 11 30 a.m
every day it's always a good time always
great food always got great drinks
flowing and if you need to hear more of
me in this type of setting check out the
we'll see you in hell podcast I'm over
at uh on patreon with my buddy Pat Walsh
reviewing movies on that show
patreon.com
wsyih podcast or you can get the back
catalog for free wherever you get your
podcast taste buds coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds hey Tasties welcome to
t-a-s-d-e buzz we're back again with a
new battle on that battle is text
messaging versus phone call all right oh
now listen I think this one is gonna get
heated but I also thought the last
episode we did which was uh happy hour
versus uh uh brunch wasn't gonna get
that heated I thought there was going to
be a pretty friendly whatever that got
hot yeah that got hot well you know what
happens it always gets hot when you stop
being irrational because then we don't
know where to go we're gonna do this now
you're gonna do this yeah
what happened it gets it gets heated
when you get irrational because we don't
know where to go from there it's hard to
have a rational a rational irrational
conversation you slipping I see what
you're doing I don't know what happened
why I see what you're doing I'm not
doing anything your head's stupid all
right you know what it's from no and I
don't care don't tell me Well if you
don't know what it's from how do you
know it's stupid
the way it looks on your head is stupid
is it too tight and your head looks
stupid really with the hat on it we
didn't say salty yet
you you want to slip I'll slip you want
to save that facility or no no you
didn't say this for sure
your head now huh
what is DX
it's uh actually the the hat that one of
the guys wears in The Outsiders movie
it's I think it's the the gas station or
something like that that they work on
it's cool it's a little like you won't
know unless you know kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah I like that I got it at the
outside of his house in Tulsa oh yeah
yeah you guys if you're ever in Tulsa go
check out Danny Boy uh uh the proprietor
and go see The Outsiders house he's
refurbished it and he's got all this all
the like stuff from the movie in it
who's Danny Boy Oh Danny Boy is the guy
who used to be in House of paying wait
that Danny Boy yes he's the proprietor
yes
he lives in Tulsa I think it's Tulsa
yeah wait do you know Danny Boy yes I
love House of Payne yes I'm like I'm
obsessed with House of Payne we should
we he would come on the Pod Danny are
you kidding me without a doubt I'll I'll
let I'll get Danny Boy next time he's
here he'll come on the pod doesn't he do
baseball stuff too or something that I'm
unaware of uh but I know that um his
life and business out there so he I
don't I met him there but we he was so a
generous I talked to him for I'm going
to tell at least at least two hours he
talked to me veter and Chris Johnson and
he just told us stories and we talked
about everything man
you know it was Danny Boy Danny Boy yeah
he was a real sweet guy he was had great
stories he was really like personable
like he was just a really nice guy we
hit it off right away we said that and I
think I've shot I thought I shouted him
out prior to this but
um check him out he's got an Instagram
account and then uh when he comes next
time out we said we were going to get
together I'll tell him to come on the
Pod I think he might have even known
about the Pod I'm maybe I'm wrong but I
love Danny Boy we tried to get Everlast
on sort of well
huh I I don't know they they are not
they don't speak I don't think
oh really yeah that's a bummer yeah you
know can I ask you guys a question about
the Battle sure why wasn't FaceTime and
audio messages included
it went better in today's battle phone
verse text message
phone call FaceTime versus I Don't Know
audio message nah FaceTime FaceTime I
think face I think you're sleeping on
FaceTime yeah we're but we're going old
school that would have been that would
have been if someone was here and said
FaceTime that would have been a nice
triplet
because FaceTime is video calling it's
it's FaceTime can shove it up its ass
yeah I mean honestly Face Time honestly
Facebook honestly I don't want to
FaceTime with anyone except the people I
want to FaceTime with so FaceTime is
great so like stay in touch with my
family you know when I'm on the road but
I don't want to like someone to call
that would normally have to call me for
some reason if somebody that you just
met jump into a FaceTime
what the [__] no that's that's like that
Trend now where everything's zoomed now
I'm like I'm not getting on this film
man zoom zoom gets on its knees
and thanks the Lord for covid I mean it
made that product covid made that
product there would be no Zoom if it
wasn't for them there were different
kinds at first but then Zoom was the
quick we ran away remember WebEx yeah
WebEx is still around is that it I see
my my my
um my financial advisor uses WebEx I'd
get rid of him I actually I I actually
think the bonfire used it too they did
that's how they do it yeah they should
drive me crazy
shout out to the bonfire shout out to
bonfire watch the bonfire on Sirius XM
listen to the listen to it listen to it
no but you could watch it on YouTube
radio show
but they do have clips on YouTube now
yeah let's not try to retroactively make
what you said you can watch it you can
watch it you listen where's the LIE
where's the uh where's the thing that's
sounding accurate I like the Hat better
now that I know Danny Boy gave it to you
no no no no I'll let him know when he
comes here what you said about it
when I die bury me
that's a Danny Boyle dude that guy is
six seven I know he's huge yeah he's
huge uh and he's in he's I think he's I
don't know if they're still doing it but
he was in LA coka Nostra which is
another yeah he was with hillbillon yeah
I don't know if he is he might have done
I don't I don't know if he is um but um
he's a cool dude and I'll tell you when
we were leaving well I was like dude
it's so nice to meet you did he give you
dirt on everland did he just tell you I
got dirt on a lot is it stuff you could
say on the part no I'm not gonna repeat
any of his things that's for him to
repeat okay I mean he didn't
he talked about every little thing and I
heard you know some stories he has some
stories about this that the other you
know but uh
all right yeah but it was cool he when
we were leaving I'm like dude thank you
so much so generous I love talking to
him we might have talked for hours at
this place and then he was like yeah and
I'm like so let's hang him and he come
he he comes to he visits he also comes
to Staten Island he knew Staten Island I
think his brother lives on Staten Island
oh wow yeah and then he goes at the end
he goes all right let's go and when we
leave he's like yeah and he goes all
right let me get your math
oh that is so cool that's for pro number
yeah yeah wow I used to say that back in
the day you don't remember that no we
didn't say that where I lived oh you're
math yeah that was like a regional thing
here and we always said digits digits we
said digits but math was math was it too
but I never said math that's cool but
math is cool right isn't it very cool I
was like oh so cool I'll give him my
math that's very cool yeah you know
that's funny that he's that we're
talking about phone terminology
on the phone battle that's right yeah
that's interesting so all right look at
me nothing will ever when did text
messaging begin wow is it a day December
3rd 1992
no look at this 1984 the SMS concept was
first developed in the franco-german
cooperation
cooperation in 1984 cooperation
yes okay
that's not cooperation
is there a cooperation right yeah I
don't know that's weird why would it be
called a
uh maybe that's what maybe it's a code
that's yeah the first telephone call uh
what were the first words ever spoken on
the telephone call they were by
Alexander Graham Bell invento the
telephone when he made the first call on
March 10 1876 100 years before I was
born Jay's assistant Thomas Watson Mr
Watson come here I want to see you what
would you have said I would have been
like Deez Nuts now that's that's that's
huge that's huge wow you get you Googled
what when was the first call and you got
13 billion results
now I'll say this about both things
both technology no Grand Bell gets all
the credit meanwhile the guy who
invented the telephone was uh Garibaldi
and mayucci well it's classic with these
inventions it's like how Thomas Edison
takes all the credit for everything a
few blocks from my childhood home is the
Garibaldi meiucci Museum in Staten
Island really and uh if you go in there
they'll let you know that uh Alexander
Graham Bella is wrongly credited did he
like steal it from them or or is it just
hit me with that help me with the
Antonio mayucci uh
who who credit Who is credited Alexander
Graham Bell is credited with being the
event of the telephone since his patents
and demonstrations for the apparatus
designed for transmitting vocal or other
sounds telegraphically causing them were
successful but if you scroll down
attributing the true inventor inventor
specific invention can be tricky
business blah blah blue
this controversy
he's the father of the telephone get to
the point guys Antonio mayucci an
Italian immigrant began developing the
design of a talking Telegraph or
telephone in 1849. in 1871 he filed a
caveat an announcement of an invention
for his design of a talking Telegraph
and due to hardships he couldn't renew
uh the caveat his role in the invention
of the telephone was overlooked in the
United States House of Representatives
uh and they borrowed miucci's
contributions and work
so that's like yeah he he set the table
and then some guy came in and
ate off of his table that seems to be
what happens a lot in science it's a
bummer it makes you makes you sad
because you want to think that the men
that are credited with these great
inventions are Men of Integrity men of
uh Prosperity you're right men of
Promise the great thinkers and you find
out that they kind of also have that
shitty sort of La Hollywood side to them
where they just it said that you know it
said that some people it said there was
because they they would it was debatable
who would get the patent and they gave
it to Belle and then they just said
there was possible malfeasance and I
just want to say the reason I said that
is because malfeasance is a fun word
it's not used a lot it is a fun word
isn't it but look at all these guys
Edison and the light bulb [__]
Einstein theory relativity [__]
Fleming and penicillin [__] these
are all guys that get the credit when
they're not really deserving of all the
credit I mean they've they're deserving
of contributions but
like you on this podcast
wow you're throwing bows dude you're
throwing bows you you started it I
didn't start [__] today it started I
didn't start what did I start you were
getting salty
where did I start that's salty huh you
got salty you're full of sodium today I
didn't start what did I start even
you've been prodding poking
prodding yeah no I'm seeing on this
episode you started in you had an
antagonist this is good for the show
I think there's
there's a stick undercurrent
uh no no I think on this episode you
started throwing passive bows early
before I didn't I didn't throw anything
wow I didn't throw anything look at
these two wow this just showed up
yeah do you guys want to join us for
this episode of taste buds we're doing
no
but you kind of already joined us
no you can't
I told you there's a little Chinese lady
out there who's waving her fist up at
the window she's mad dude we got it's
Bobby Lee
we got hot in the last episode she kept
saying calm down and I don't know if
she's saying come down or calm down
cause I'm just pissed she's saying come
Town Oh Come town oh she loves
they also feel she thinks it's them oh
yeah yeah we continue on continue on
sorry thank you it's all right well
you're kind of on now the show is like
yeah
well no if you guys just yeah walk
around and talk
so you're not coming on all right listen
let's get to the battle it's it's
messages versus phone calls right now
okay
so you don't need that you don't need
it's okay
well before we tell you who we are
tell me what you think I don't want you
to be I don't text messages first phone
calls 100 uh text messages gonna win big
okay no but what do you like better oh I
like a phone call it's more it's more
it's it's more I like a phone call from
a friend text me if you don't know me
that well you don't know me that well
shoot me a text no no no are you my real
friend pick up the phone what's your
preferred
preferred way of communication well with
a high level of convenience I you have
to text but my but I wish we could all
call our friends
that's different now that's different
it's a different the argument is which
way do you prefer to communicate
you can you can keep one and you got it
I'm gonna throw in a wrench
FaceTime
FaceTime pimp just said it yeah you
that's how you prefer to have all your
communication I prefer text message at
the bottom of the list because I have
black friends unlike you guys and they
only FaceTime black people only FaceTime
sure but you have but you also have to
FaceTime all you're saying with that
you're saying you have to FaceTime
everyone even the blacks and everyone
else no no no no no no no no no no
everybody knows everybody non-black it's
whatever it is what it is no but you
can't just say I want FaceTime with my
black friends I face my black friends I
text my black friends come on they don't
like you that much they
I FaceTime black people I FaceTime my
mom and my girl I FaceTime black people
yeah I I phone call I phone call Joe
right uh I voice text him
um that's because he says the n-word
[Laughter]
you better not keep those things
all right let's go back let's go back to
the real to the real at hand before this
gets too wonky
I would prefer a call but it's
impossible sure sure I know it's
impossible when I want to speak to a
friend yeah yeah that ideal thing is
let's get on the phone let's talk but
I'm talking about your day-to-day life
if you had to eliminate one you have to
eliminate the phone call oh no I would
eliminate text messages because that
would make you call me and you know what
it would do it would it would deter you
from sending me a [__] text that you
shouldn't have said but you you would
wait you would hold it off until the
phone there would be no way believe it
or not I genuinely believe if you
eliminated the text message you and just
phone calls you would get so much more
time back in your life because barely
that's what I'm saying a thousand
percent
in society by only taking phone calls
not these days no we have surpassed them
hold on you have to have the bandwidth
you have to multitask you can't get done
with you can't get done with things with
phone calls that you can with text
messages
when we didn't have text you think it
was less efficient then or it's just you
just you know it's a better it's a more
idealistic world if I could if I can go
back to the time when there was just
phone calls yeah I'd go back but
everything else technology wise would
have to go back with it yeah you can't
just eliminate text messages today and
just have phone calls okay you you would
fall apart at the scene but no you'd
figure out a better way I text message
50 000 times a month
hold on let's start the battle let's
start the battle you're puking it all
out all right yeah yeah yeah sorry I
thought we had a format here all right I
I did too
it's an artistic Choice
I'm saying let's start The Battle Before
you know your good points do it let's do
it
ran the show for eight weeks without you
but uh she's gonna have you back
I have to be
all right
I agree with what Chris just said by the
way you can't see him on camera people
the pig is in the house he's over there
behind the TV back baby
pig is in the house I agree with Chris
text me I'm team phone call text message
I truly believe has led to the crumbling
of interpersonal relationships of true
communication I would say social media
has done that social media is part of
the texting so texting came about with
T9 in 2000 and texting was still good
back then let me tell you what let me
tell you everything is delivering let me
tell us let me tell you what texting is
contributed to it has contributed to a
lack of understanding tone and what a
person is saying it has created this is
true it has created massive anxiety
issues for people because when they see
the phone ring now younger people a lot
will get nervous because they think it
means it's something bad is about to
happen or they're about to get yelled at
or whatever that's an absurd thing to
bring into this it's Sal it's not an
absurd saying that let me tell you has
made phone calls Sal let me finish the
point and I will tell you why my friend
who is a photo who produces photo shoots
has told me several times with all of
the younger people that he has to hire
he has to tell them via text I'm about
to call you it's everything is okay
please pick up because they shy away
from phone calls so much okay I don't
know what has to do with anything what
do you mean so you're saying text
messages ruined phone calls for people
you never got a text message that that
said call me and you start to get
anxiety because you're like wait wait
wait wait wait wait what's that what's
that what's that sure but that's Marvel
that's just more of the overuse of text
messaging has created a social anxiety
for people it is unarguable okay I I
think you're not remembering what it
means to take a phone call for every
[__] thing that's not what I'm saying
if you had to pick up the phone every
time it rang all day long and then get
into a conversation and try and get out
of a conversation with someone I think
the wheels would fall off your life but
that's not what I'm saying I'm making
points against text messaging and why I
think text messages are bad I'm not here
to promote I'm not arguing the
idealistic theories here obviously a
phone call is more interpersonal a phone
call is more intimate a phone call is
nicer when you want to talk to a friend
I'm not arguing the idealism of it I'm
arguing right now what if you had to
eliminate one which is the way you're
going to communicate more you can argue
I would need to eliminate the phone call
well that's you I would eliminate text
messages but I know how to plan my life
in a given day how many texts do you do
too many it drives me [__] crazy I
can't get a moment's [__] piece in a
given day how many do you do it's got
It's dozens and dozens every day I'm in
hundreds probably that's crazy it is but
my point is is that that is where the
speed we're at that's what's coming
everything and I will tell you people
expect we'll tell you why you're wrong I
will tell you why you're everybody slows
down I will tell you go back to phone I
will tell you why you're wrong you are
somebody and I swear I don't mean this
is a personal attack maybe a little bit
yes he does you are somebody that loves
to to write
chap I know you talked to Q about it
hold on yeah yeah so it's funny I know I
know you're going with this no no I had
long text let me tell you something
right now let me
let me use with nice texts you know what
happens their reference points ciao let
me finish this I had somebody [__] off
text
s and you don't like to you will send
multiple ones the interaction in and of
itself would take far less time if we
hopped on the phone for 30 seconds and
discussed it not sure absolutely with
you no please not true not true I gotta
go no my phone bill's gonna be expensive
text I don't remember anything you wrote
it's over right it's too much
information
I had something happen recently where a
construction job at my house delivered
the wrong thing and I told the guy I
said I talked to you about this
specifically he said no you didn't it
was the other thing and I said really
and I went back and thankfully I texted
him it and I showed him it he was dead
to rights he said I apologize I'll fix
the problem
because it's it's written it's like it's
like it's like in [__] uh uh sideways
when Paul Giamatti is asking Thomas
what's his face about the changes from
the Verizon commercials yeah yeah but
that scene when he's asking Thomas
what's his face about about it the
changes he made in his book and he's
like yeah I liked it man and bloody
money goes [__] nothing was changed
after page 735 it's like that's what
your texts are like which sounds like we
discussed this it was in paragraph six
the 17th texts
conversely conversely let's go in on you
hey guys just want to let you know for
the month coming up I crunch all the
numbers so we can shoot on these days
and I'm good from these times to this
times just let me know what you guys
want to do full thing a couple weeks
later Joe goes hey guys I don't know
when are we doing everything guys what
that's the deal how many episodes do we
have and how many episodes do we need
and what time are you free I want to and
we say Joe we already did all of this
everything is detail I don't do that
they'll work for you I don't need to do
a report I don't do the questions you
have and then you don't read it and then
you call me in a tissy going I'm driving
this has never happened and when is this
never happened you want to open this
open this kid to work yeah there's two
people don't do this yeah
you don't wanna oh my God I think we
should go down that road I'm talking
about texts holy [__] are you crazy
you're talking about one time
[Music]
I swear to God well they should know
about how you do things
for a big like that is when we're trying
to figure [__] out and it's always like
all right I can do this and this what
about you guys and there's a big
dialogue and then we then I sometimes
I'll even go okay guys I gotta you guys
gotta uh yeah sorry I'm sorry sure the
people down there that was just a call
from the owner he was like I can't have
you guys like they think the people
Easter think there's a fight going on
upstairs they're about to call the
police yeah
the people that are upset would they
call or text the police
if you could text the police if you
could text the police you'd text how you
know you wouldn't you would because no
you would never text the police they
would know you're [__] around your
voice is serious hello I'm an emergency
again again all I'm saying I'm talking
about right now what I'm talking about
is the need not ideally a phone call is
better than a text of course it is but
in this day and age to keep up with
Society if you had to eliminate one you
gotta eliminate the phone call right
this is no way you could do as much work
and receive and give as much information
while you're doing your day as text
messages the world has passed text
messages and emails lead to needless
communication it's over abundant if you
talk it out this pros and cons if let me
let me show you what exactly you had to
eliminate one this today today if you
had to eliminate one I'll tell you
exactly you wouldn't have to eliminate
phone calls I'll tell you exactly what I
mean
yesterday and I will I will make fun of
Chris for a second by the way that whole
rant there
is very one-sided we talked through this
thing there was there was both we had
both of you took a shot at me you took a
shot at me about that that is not
reading a long text message
said crazy personal [__] and you touched
back on those other things that we
already covered that's [__] wash
that you I'm talking about you not
reading long technology hold on a second
don't act like you didn't prod the
personal [__] first hasn't that happened
uh enough time has happened more than
one time
I would it it's definitely happened once
um trying to think if it's happened more
times to be fair I never read the text
messages either
but that's that's what all I'm saying
that's unfair uh yeah to be fair I'm
just whenever you guys are like let's do
it I'm just like all right I'll I'll do
it but I do
I I do think that what I think gets lost
between all of us the most is the voice
notes I think the the law so I know this
episode's not about the voice notes but
I think the voice notes if I could just
find a way to deflect I'm gonna go in on
The Voice Notes
well I will say too a lot of a lot of
the reasons that I that the paragraphs
are coming from me is because
unfortunately I have the more on
reasonable schedule and you guys a lot
of times generously have to plan around
where I am so I give you information I
don't understand a world in which
somebody has the time to type that
amount of information versus talking it
out for 30 seconds I just don't get it I
never will that's not a shot at you
that's a shot at everybody you look at
it wouldn't be spoken to you look at the
average text thread and this is this is
what I'm talking about with
communication breakdown and attention
breakdown or whatever you get it's it's
it's
one thought text it's next thought test
next
you look at grammar breakdown you look
at the misspellings they had to add an
edit button that you could post edit the
text you already sent because there's so
many typos there's so many grammatical
errors everything gets sent
instantaneously knee-jerk no thought
nothing if you sit down like a human
being and collect your thoughts and say
we will speak at a time and you do that
you know you don't need to be texting
not not sure at all you're getting so
granular with the pros and cons of of
typos I I'm talking about broad okay if
you too if you had to live without one
of them today and still get all the [__]
you need to get done and survive the
right way you'd have to eliminate phone
calls I text with easily easily easily
20 people if not 50 people a day I can't
make all those calls I think you're I
think you're of but you're even you
cannot survive with just phone calls 100
you cannot right 100 okay so you want to
make a wager let's think about it in the
next week
I will not make a single phone call I'll
only use text in the next week you do
not text a single person I can't do that
because everybody oh my God no because
no shout because everybody texting me is
expecting me to text back well that's
part of it bro oh stop it no no no no no
you don't all you gotta do is call the
person you're just call the person
you're saying Joe just call the person
doing that so why because because the
the girl I might have a date with the
the the the the my landlord it's your
your talk you're I'm talking from a
place you don't send a text
you don't send a text just call this
whole week one week you don't send a
text you just call I won't make a call
I'll just text who do you think's gonna
have a tougher week I'm not it's you're
it I think you should do it
I think you should try it try it for a
week so this next week if I told you for
this next week you can't send one text
or this next week you can't make one
call which one would you choose which
one would I choose yes if you send off I
can't make one call or I can't make one
text for this next seven days what would
be harder it what would be harder would
be to not text right so right you would
choose you would give up calls for the
week yes because I'd say I need to at
least text but right this is my but this
is my full argument but also
choosing is different I bet you put it
in a bit different perspective if you
did just calls for the week if somebody
texted you you called them right back
and say hey something's wrong with my
text that could be your excuse and then
you could own and somebody calls you
cannot pick up the phone then you have
to text them I would argue at the end of
the week he would be happier talking to
more people on the phone than you would
only texting people I would argue I
would disagree because I already lived
my life this way phone calls are like
yeah I mean that's like ten percent part
of this bargain you're asking you're
you're not making any change and you're
asking me to make a drastic change I
don't text because I like I can't make
it any change I make phone calls I'm
just telling you I won't make a single
one what what are you talking about Joe
just said I already lived my life this
way predominantly followed buy I make
phone calls yes I predominantly
understand the words you don't
understand nuanced Joe huh I
predominantly text so it'd be easier for
me to give up phone calls do you not is
that is that something that's going to
blow you up top the only yeah the only
like a janitor the only reason I don't
predominantly make phone calls is
because we live in a predominantly
texting world you trust me if this world
we live in eliminated one which would I
prefer I would take phone calls and I
would never go I wish we had those texts
back because it was so much that's how I
argue that we the world would have to
eliminate one of these forms of
communication is a silly premise to
argue it was your premise no I said if
you had to if you had to choose one to
use only you and I said you can't only
choose phone calls because the world is
so technology advanced you wouldn't be
able to keep up with just phone calls
it's almost impossible now it's it's
it's it's it's a necessity text and
that's the thing I'm basing my argument
on not if the world could eliminate one
of those things I said that necessity
has made us worse for the wear you said
that that was too meta and that was too
much I said the words pros and cons but
but despite those I still got to go with
text because according to this article
texting hinders all types of
communication including written
face-to-face and surface level it also
causes problems with social social
boundaries and worsens our impatience
and needs for kids that grew up only
texting truly yeah and then and this is
on the heels of 10 minutes ago you
saying there's absolutely no Foundation
to me saying that younger people get
anxiety from the concept of a phone call
that is a hundred percent true folks
this episode of taste buds is brought to
you by better help long time standing
sponsor of the show better help is great
and I'm going to just throw this out at
the top you're going to go to
betterhelp.com taste buds and get on
your way to being your best self now why
am I telling you to go there and what do
I mean by with what I just said I will
tell you your best self means when
you're at your best you're doing great
things but the problem is life and life
can get you bogged down it can get you
feeling overwhelmed it can make you feel
like you don't really want to show up or
maybe not able to show up in the way
that you'd ultimately want to working
with a therapist can really help it can
help you get closer to that best version
of you because when you feel empowered
you're more prepared to take on
everything that life throws at you and I
look at empowerment not as some big
robust chest out stance uh you know of
meaning literal power I'm in my opinion
empowerment just means comfort in your
own skin
not letting the anxiety and the hiccups
and the hurdles and whatever else get in
the way of you doing what you got to do
for you and for those around you just
being the best you to me that's what
empowerment is so if you've ever thought
of giving therapy a try because maybe
this has been an issue for you better
help is a great option I use it I used
it today before I came down here I like
my therapist quite a bit and I like the
service quite a bit it's convenient it's
flexible it's affordable it's entirely
online so
you go over to the to the website and
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
and you get matched with a licensed
therapist and at any point you can
switch therapists at no additional
charge it's just so good it's so
affordable it's so easy it's there to
help better help if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhelp.com tastebuds as
I said at the top you're going to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com taste buds you said that you
you said that when young people see the
phone ring they get anxiety attacks no I
didn't say anxiety
is a bit of a blanket statement
no
sure I mean
can someone get anxiety when they get a
text gave you a specific and you rolled
your eyes at the specificity that my a
friend of mine who manages a large
quantity of people in their 20s as
freelance workers for the photo shoots
he produces said he frequently has to
warn them via text that he's going to
call them sure because they avoid phone
calls okay so so great but that's not
really gonna win the argument of of one
or the other you're picking it up you're
telling me
I'm saying despite the negatives despite
them you gotta take texting over phone
calls despite them I'm not arguing
against the negatives I'm just saying it
doesn't [__] matter it's like saying
despite the arguments of land mines
don't pick up the [__] phone I'm not
getting on the phone with that guy I
can't get off the phone they Yap all the
time what about being like I sent three
words to someone and I said oh I need to
say to them and I go on my day what
about the point of I can't remember this
[__] person but I don't want to get
on hold them thank God but it's but it's
not Jesus but it's never that it's never
I said three words in your head it is
it's not that though it's it's bro we
got we got it down to a thumb we got it
down we're going back to hieroglyphics
now okay that's how we communicate I
could send someone a thumb and I tell
them what I need to tell them instead of
going
hello it sounds good to me all right we
gotta go to the phone I send the thumb I
send a thumb all parties know yeah
that's why
do you think that every time we had to
talk the four of us had to get on a
party line and talk to each other about
it I don't think we have to talk as much
as we ever do I I think you don't
if the four of us had to get on a call
every time we had to book something you
would rip your dick off okay you texting
has positives too
you can't go a whole week without text
this is the I rest my in the world we
live in of course I can't you can't go
the whole week without a phone call
yes I can I can do it that's very
one-sided and privileged of you then I
don't know what else to say what what
are you talking about that's a nice
place to live in that you can go tough
[__] if you don't like my texting I
don't have that [__] Advantage I have
to you'll never have that Advantage
because you don't think highly enough of
yourself
my point is is
I would say this the fight we got into
that you referenced first no I didn't
Joe I referenced something general and
you took it to mean that specific thing
when I can tell you to your face right
now that's not what I meant but you
won't believe me but you just gotta but
let's talk about what just happened you
got the building in trouble no we both
used you were yelling first now what are
you talking about Joe the level you just
yelled was more than any episode you've
ever yelled at in your life I've never
even seen that face on you before they
did say somebody was the guy who's loud
must be in a bad religion shirt yeah
yeah that's what they said thank you so
so let me figure out I didn't mean that
thing let me get pushed sure but sure
that's what it sounded like you meant
but and I was responding but also if I
meant and I was pissed because I was
like we'd squash this and you're going
to bring it up like that and I think
that's shitty I didn't bring up the
reason we had an argument you what you
thought I brought up was the fact that I
sent a text that you didn't read no why
would you dig into the fact
okay are all the taste buds this fun
yeah yeah oh good this is what they want
okay
none of this is anything true none of
this is anything serious it's all
stemming from the argue from the nucleus
of the of the of the battle
you might be taking this way more
seriously than you should I don't know I
couldn't take offense to it I got up on
a tear and I ran with it as we often do
on the show but I didn't take offense to
any of that I I I I I I really I first I
thought you were like doing funny then I
was like he looks so mad then I thought
it was funny that you were so mad but
again none of it really matters
all right it's not that heavy man with
argument phone call versus text
messaging
keep that part in
keep that part in uh
uh let's go to the smart move to not be
on camera
what time are we at let's just say
anyway make a closing statement about
texts and uh phone calls uh
[Music]
uh yeah I just I just I think Texas way
more efficient I think that I can get
way more done with it I'm a person that
has a lot of things on my plate a lot so
I need ways to manage my time better uh
I don't disagree about the negative
aspects of texting I was hinging my
argument on the fact that in this day
and age I can live without one and not
the other
I think that it's impossible to live
without texting at this point but that
is a horrible horrible reflection of
society I agree and that that's a big
problem I agree with that though so
idealistic I can only argue this
idealistically and I can only argue that
to this day I still prefer a phone call
I think we're picking up for different
handles and I think that was the issue
here I think that you're arguing the
good things and the bad things for each
and I'm arguing if I had to live without
one which would I choose despite any of
those points yeah so we we are really
kind of going at it from a different way
I think this episode proves texting has
a tonality issue
that nobody can get past I agree with
that right I agree well so does enlive
in person has there's a tonality issue
apparently because nobody knew what was
going on there either
all right I didn't know I didn't know
how to receive that that might as well
have been a text
come back
I never tell what he's real or fake or
whatever I don't know I couldn't tell
you that was wild that was fun I think
it was fun man I like a DeRosa wait a
minute why am I the only crazy one here
though no you fed each other you fed
each other I mean it
why am I the only you were getting wild
too you were up out of here you got you
yeah no no I I indeed but I think I
think the level that you got to I didn't
go to that
so we're just talking about that was my
level that much higher I think you won
I felt like the level wasn't that much
different than where we were at that was
the highest level I've ever seen you at
I genuinely I'm not kidding
when you spit I'm not even kidding at
all you feel his life it's wet his leg
is actually wet he's a lot of when you
spit I saw it come out and I thought
it's 4K
it would be nice at least have it while
I'm in town but I don't want you to but
I am here I was leaning into it a bit
that would be if you would have heard of
that I would have had to have I would
have had this forever I thought it was
gonna be funny
after the fact but then you said that it
was personal and I was like ah [__] all
right here we are well I think it was
personal I just thought it was weird
that you bring up one specific fight
when I'm just talking about text
messaging I I know I thought I was only
I thought you were we already talked I
thought you said I was all right spider
I thought you were hanging up the fight
I should hug well this is uh this is the
Hallmarks the Hallmarks of a strong
friendship moments ago they were we were
swinging from the rafters right now
we're calmly talking it out
it's all good I think it came full
circle I think it shows how strong of a
bond we actually have
I think it's guaranteed Joe kills
himself tonight
send this send a note via text
yeah
uh all right don't call me unless you're
being kidnapped
and then text first that's very funny
hey someone calls me I immediately say
is there a fire did someone die do I
need to go to Home Depot and make a cash
only purchase
if it's important let's sit down in
person otherwise phone calls are just
filler get to the point
while it's easier to determine sarcasm
and jokes and phone calls I never answer
my phone when someone calls I have to go
with text
my depression makes me ignore both
this is these these comments are
legitimately making me sad I still have
a landline but the only person I talked
about on the phone is my mother every
Sunday
this speaks to such a massive social
issue personal because I don't disagree
there though that's what I'm saying I
don't disagree with those things I know
but I mean it's just it's
you know how how how can we def why do
we continue to use a thing that's so bad
for us it's honestly depends but if it's
scroll down it honestly depends on the
situation but if it's not important or
complicated text all the way personal by
text work by email
uh Twitter replies is usually a good too
the only phone call anyone gets is spam
text message always I rarely pick up the
phone idiotic blanket statement the only
phone call
anybody gets this all right I'm clearly
going to lose this
uh you can hear my disappointment there
you go thank you for talking to you over
a text message thank you you can't hear
you can't get the socially anxious and
awkward fan base we've got going on here
huh yes you're absolutely right yeah but
again I don't disagree those things I'm
just telling you that you crazy if you
think you could live on on only phone
call instead of only text
alternative voice notes that's that's a
happy medium as a matter of fact that's
something that we yes exercise yes so
there's our happy medium I agree yeah I
agree
imagine calling someone to laugh at a
meme
sexting is terrible reason enough to
love the phone
if I get a phone call I mean I think
something's wrong
only if it's really really really
important phone calls text kids and
young adults hate the phone
here's one too easy to misunderstand
each other via texting that's very true
don't ever call me I mean I don't know
man it's yeah but you know
I get why these people are saying texts
despite the fact that it's it sucks it's
terrible that's that was my argument
from the get okay it seems here that
it's going to be a lopsided thing okay
what's what's better one-on-one just
nothing else considered a phone call 100
to zero percent but to function and to
to do what I need to do if I had to
choose one I'm choosing a text I think
it's a very sound
pragmatic approach to this
all right I think what you were doing
was arguing is a phone call better than
a text and on paper and just in general
it is that's my argument but I'm gonna
lose it doesn't matter all right yeah I
mean it's
it's this is being met with this is
being met with all the comments here are
supporting every single negative thing I
said about texting people saying things
like if I get a phone call it must be a
problem it's like it's crazy like it's
just it's just a bad way that we live
you read emails you read written
messages in the form of email and text
messages from people in their 40s and
50s that that no longer know how to
properly write a message because they've
become so reliable on their phone fixing
it for them it's embarrassing but the
thing is is I agree with everything you
just said no no I know but I I can't my
point is though I would take a text
message and and in the battle all right
let's let's just go to the vote
only call me Humble Pie you see that one
only call me if you're in the ditch
all right this is let's see
all right we got 10 200 votes
uh I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna tank on
this clearly there's a bunch of people
that didn't comment voted
I mean that's crazy that's crazy
so Humble Pie here what a depressing
drum roll uh text message wins
85.3 to 14.7 percent
I do think FaceTime would have damaged
this I think it would only be like 60.
you would have been your FaceTime would
have been a disrupter
I mean how many people are using
facetimes they're FaceTime FaceTime is
amazing for the for the people that I
want to FaceTime with it's a small group
and then that's it you don't understand
women use it to vet if somebody's a
creep before dating app like it's used
as a tool like I get it as as far as all
that goes but I mean your people are
pissing and moaning about picking up a
phone and getting to the point they want
to commit to a screen and a look
for for to exchange simple information
that's nuts that's I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying if that's the case
that's nuts
all right
I still love you babe love you too taste
buds they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right